bionoves one of the two bees in abba
welcome to the economist asks
thank you we were just chatting as we're
getting going and i was telling you that
i have the original single of waterloo
1974 with your eurovision breakthrough
when you meet people like me
who have followed abba and abba's
afterlife yeah for what is now
four decades i was obviously very small
at the time
um do you think oh my goodness it's that
long or
what do you feel when you meet very
long-standing fans
it's quite strange um
i mean intellectually i can understand
figures huge figures of you know sold
records and stuff like that but
emotionally
it's quite difficult to grasp
that it has meant a lot
to a lot of people over a long period of
time
and that you and i are sitting here
talking about this
something which i thought would you be
you know
gone into oblivion like
two years after we'd split up so
i'm i'm i'm very humbled by it when
people come up to me and tell me
how much our music has meant
um and grateful but i have to
say that i don't know quite how that
happened
well let's try and find out a little bit
as we look forward as well because
mamma mia the movie is back mamma mia 2.
tell me why you decided to take mamma
mia forward you had this
big hit with the musical stage yeah
and film yeah you might think like three
times is
pushing luck yes but you did it why
um well obviously universal
pictures they wanted mamma mia too much
earlier
so there's been talk about it for these
past 10 years
and there have been a few scripts as
well
um either it's not after liking them or
hollywood but then when
old parker and richard curtis came up
with this idea
of telling two stories uh and when i saw
all parker's first draft i thought ah
this is this is fun you know
we could actually do this this would be
great to see this movie
is what i felt and and and benny too so
he said yes
okay let's go ahead does it take the
four of you to give permission for
something to go ahead
in this case we're talking about um
music and lyrics
so it's so it's it's really uh
benny and me but of course we talked to
the girls as well about it
ladies about it like anything that
concerns abba we all for
talk about it and then you have to have
other people performing your songs
whoever's in the movie gets to sing
their songs
uh pleasurable occasionally painful
some some actors don't have to sing that
much
which means that you have more freedom
in kind of choosing them
whereas um main characters like
donna the uh the part played by mary
streep
in the first one we have the young donna
in in in this one and
lily james and she sings like a goddess
and then the other main character is of
course sophie donna's daughter
and that's amanda seaford who also sings
even better than she did 10 years ago
very
very lucky with with those and christine
baranski is a great singer
so they mostly um they sing very well
most of them and you don't try to
replicate
an abba sound because it is it's
extremely distinctive
anyone switching on a radio yeah knows
when it's happening
yes um it's very distinctive and we
actually recorded two songs with abba
again
this is about a year ago two new songs
um and then you know the minute those
two ladies went into the studio
and opened their mouths and sang
together wow
that's abba and it doesn't sound like
anything else i'm interested in why you
did that
because you had said it in the past
you'd like people to remember
abba as they were young exuberant full
of energy and ambition
yeah well you still seem pretty
exuberant and full of energy and
ambition but other
is a bit same goes for all of us huh
but abba is older and it does feel like
a bit of a risk
to put it back together again because
again
because it was a challenge uh
something nobody had ever done before so
what we're doing is that we're creating
heads digital humans of ourselves
from 1979 that's the year we chose i
think
the ladies did we looked particularly
good then apparently
so you will see those avatars
and you you will not see that they're
not human beings
but they are digital humans and they
will sing
the new songs that we have recorded the
avatars
yes so through their lips
will come the voices of agneto
and freda of today and what did it feel
like to to do that again given that so
many of the songs particularly towards
the back end whenever was together were
quite
sad quite reflective and there's a sort
of goodbye a melancholy feeling
yeah to the lyrics what's the feeling of
the new songs what i know you're
recapturing and
but also looking forward so how do you
strike that balance
well uh first of all we we just
wrote two new songs as best we could
without ever thinking about you know
another single competing with the others
in the charts or anything like that
one of them is it's like a pop song
from the 70s the other one is kind of
timeless
but they're both reflective
especially the one called i still have
faith in you
it's almost existential
and it reflects on on the four of us and
the life we have now
um so i guess we didn't even
think we just did what you know what
what
seemed to be the best at the time which
was one year ago and
and i'm very proud of both songs
actually can you give us a line from one
of the songs
no get one a small exclusive
oh that's uh i still have faith in you
and don't shut me down
it's the other one we'll have to wait
and see when will we hear them
i think it's been pushed um
ahead a little or back
one of the two one of the two um
it was planned for the end of this year
but i think we're talking about the
beginning of next year now
i know a bit about your lyrics i like
your lyrics
a lot and i've always been fascinated by
the way you were able to combine this
bouncy pop style
dancing queen and mamma mia with quite
serious subjects that you've written
about
divorce there's you used the word
existential the moment ago which
doesn't sort of think of so much with
disco hits
what topics do you want to address now
in music
i'm still interested in relationships
of various kinds
not necessarily boy falling in love with
girl but
other other aspects as well and i
that's why i usually land i i find
politics stuff like that
quite uninteresting for
music it's it's very often that the
music
tells me what it's about uh
it kind of conjures up
images or even like film sequences in my
head
you know when i hear something which
doesn't have words
and then it's just a matter of writing
down writing that down in
lyric form and telling a little story
the story that i see in my head you make
it sound quite easy
it is it is and when people ask you that
annoying question of
what's the secret to writing a pop song
um you have to be very
uh true to yourself and serious
um and
you have to trust your own
taste and and your own
intuitions um
don't speculate
get inspiration from other people and
from other songs
don't copy write your own things
and if you're lucky some other people
will like it as well
i wondered given that so much time has
elapsed from the mid
70s through 80s
and beyond you when music changed a lot
but so did society
and you track a lot of society i think
particularly european society
in your songs in in small ways are there
songs that you now look back
i would not right now and i'm thinking
something like does your mother know
that you're out
which in the metoo era and a sort of
greater awareness and squeamishness uh
you know of you know a sort of possibly
exploitative relationships with younger
women
yeah maybe not so much beyond maybe i
hesitated today you're absolutely right
but there was this young girl you know
that i must have met sometime during my
career
um on tour perhaps who came up to me
like that but um you know i never went
across the
limit as you can see in the song i
told her stay off take it easy you're
too young and so forth
so i'm clean conscious and do you think
the sort of
feminism has changed the way that we see
either the lyrics or the presentation of
abba you know with the
sort of gorgeous girls in their cat
suits
extraordinary wardrobes would you style
it differently now
i don't think so we had fun and and we
were
you know equals and and there was never
any
talk about anything else we
but i think the metoo
revolution especially i think in sweden
i find that
it's it's meant so much it's incredible
it has changed so much it was a
revolution i think
what was looking different me too
um we're thinking differently now but
but then again our marriages
and divorces were completely you know
on equal terms and um
so there again i have a clean conscience
i'm a feminist
always been you describe yourself i
think as a free thinker
a humanist yes what do you mean by that
well i don't
necessarily think that
human beings can sort out everything but
what else is there um we have to
do things ourselves we have to take
responsibility for everything
i mean us humans because if there is
anything else out there
ruling our lives um well we haven't seen
any of it yet
so while we're waiting for that i think
we humans have to take
responsibility for what we're doing
is there a song that you think sums up
your political outlook
small p political humanist outlook
um i'm a
liberal i'm a kind of a social liberal
um if that tells you
you know that's roughly where i am
you sound like a perfect economist
reader yeah i hope you are
yeah i i do read the the economist every
week
and uh it's it's one of uh
one of my favorites the leaders
especially i love the
leaders in the economies you should come
into one of our leader conferences
so your outlook as you say is socially
liberal it's not music it's intended to
drive a particular conclusion
but i'm also struck i mean for me
growing up with your music
it was a window into europe particularly
northern europe you have songs that are
set in in paris our last summer is also
a song about paris as well as a story
about breaking up and it had
that scandy sound that you just felt
very fresh
it was a time of perhaps greater
ambition in the eu
and the idea of a european ideal you're
here in london at a time of
brexit chaos other strains on the
european idea yes
how do you feel about that i feel very
bad about that
i'm a european through and through and
i'm
really really sad that some of the brits
feel that they you know wanna they wanna
don't wanna be among their friends
anymore
and i just don't understand it but
there you go i hope that
the rest of europe will you know
somehow find some strength to uh
withstand the populists and and those
who um
deep down want to be dictators and and
are enemies of democracy i think deep
down
um you've seen your own country change
quite a lot as well haven't you from the
your music is used in the lucas medicine
film
uh sos about changes in swedish
society from a kind of to put the boot
on the other foot so to speak that the
social democratic
ideal is also a bit tattered isn't it it
is
it's very it's very tattered um
all over europe all over the world
perhaps it's like they cannot find the
path anymore
um and they the the relevance
everyone wonders what is the relevance
in
social democracy but i think
liberal democracy um when it's
at its best in europe that's what we
must be
fighting for that's actually one of the
reasons we wanted to talk to you for a
season that we're doing called open
future which looks at
the challenges to liberal democracy uh
i'm also
interested how specifically swedish
you think your music was and is
and in the sense it has that much
sometimes i nearly went into german
which is
this is not really but it has that
depressive undertone sometimes and if i
think of something like sos
it is it's what it says it's an urgent
cry of pain about things how much do you
feel that you're
you're influenced by a sort of darker
scandinavian tradition in literature
in the poetry and so oh very much very
much
um abbas music is is described sometimes
as happy sad
and there's certainly a melancholy
underlying the
exuberant voices and the sound is so
happy and uplifting but there is
darkness underneath and there is
melancholy of a particular nordic kind i
think in it
but you said that you you found that our
music was like a window
to europe and um i think that's because
growing up benny and i were exposed to
all kinds of music through swedish radio
in
other ways so
french on song german schlager
italian ballads plus
nordic folk music and stuff together
with pop and rock and roll
we had all that in us when we started
writing
so i think we're very european at the
same time
there's the odd bit of bach in there
isn't there yeah it's there
and i think that we're the only in the
rock and roll hall of fame we're the
only non-anglo-saxon
group ever inducted which is
incredible uh question for our listeners
is which have a song has
marilyn french the feminist writer in it
um
do you remember yes you wrote
the day before you came funnily
enough on the new cast album from
mamma here we go again you can hear
mario's street as as an extra track
singing the day before you came and we
decided that no one
or or man in french is that not not that
well known
anymore people many people wonder so
many french in that mary street version
is margaret atwood ah yes now that is an
exclusive you've replaced maryland
french with margaret atwood
i'm sure we'll hear a lot from our
listeners about that choice okay i blame
it on mario
play me on merrell exactly so the world
has changed a lot in these 35 years
and i wanted you know being back here in
london launching something new you must
reflect on your own life
as well how much have have you changed
in that time and if i
interviewed with the little girl
watching waterloo in 1974
what is your if you can sum up your
personal journey what is it
well um generally as i am
73 now um
i i have more freedom
i am braver
i can make quicker decisions
i'm not as worried about everything as
that young man was
um i take it much
more easy and
i you know lift my eyes and i see the
bigger picture
much more often than he did so
if i give him advice it would be you
know
don't be so worried things will sort it
sort themselves out i think i'm going to
take
head over heels as your song to my
desert island if i have to take
oh really yes i'm taking that one i
don't think you know i
don't think this is a choice but many
others i think for young women it's a
great song
what what would you take if i had to
take an abba song i would take
some other song i wouldn't take an
episode i
i would take a symphony by beethoven
and you can have another song as well i
don't know
it's it's very difficult there are
they are like from different periods and
so
i have favorites from various different
periods we went through
i think if you listen to our albums from
beginning to end
there is a development there is uh they
are kind of
younger sounding more teenage oriented
in the beginning
and more mature towards the end but that
makes it
almost impossible to pick just one
bjor novice thank you so much for
talking to us thank you